[Musique]
c'est ma petite caverne dallas d'inde de
trésors musicaux on devrait enregistrer
des anciennes chansons sérieuses que tu
as du talent le pense vraiment tu as une
très jolie voix qui n'attend que de
sortir qu'est ce que tu veux dire rien
qui ne l'exploitent pas vraiment si
c'est comme si tu la retenue
[Musique]
y'a pas de musique tuer la musique
ton premier album aura droit à une
version en vinyle j'adore tes chansons
je me suis dit cette fille elle connaît
les trouver c'est une grosse opportunité
je connais un paquet compositeur qui
seraient prêts à écrire pour d'analystes
à rennes veut que j'écrive pour dan ali
cool
je te vois pas comme si tu étais le
simple rouage d'une grande machine
d'arrow neigé l'adorent gedar je la veux
je peux l'avouer je sais que je suis
béni ma carrière et d'aplats je n'ai pas
de famille qui voudrait être avec moi
non tu as tort je fais peur aux gens tu
ne me fait pas peur à moi
tu sais quand un chanteur trouve un
auteur qui lui ressemble c'est un
contrat à vie allez je veux m'en
prochain thibout
arrête de penser qu est ce que tu es
heureux 106 qui peut mettre ça dans ton
travail alors tu vas arriver à quelque
chose de vraiment génial
c'est tellement bien
c'est sympa j'adore
on a construit tout un monde imaginaire
et ça nous empêche de voir les choses
comme elles sont vraiment
quand on est ensemble le temps s'étire
se rallongent ce qu'il ya entre nous
notre amour pourrait sauver le monde